ho trascorso
gran parte dell'ultimo anno in
california in silicon valley e sono qui
per
con voi la mia esperienza
di start up per pugliese in silicon
valley
lo voglio fare dato che è una serata in
parte dedicata al cibo utilizzando un
linguaggio che è quello della cucina e
quindi ri visiterò il concetto di start
up di queste imprese innovative di cui
tanto si parla in versione culinaria
utilizzando delle metafore che vi
spiegano alcuni semplici concetti
riguardo l'impresa a questo talk nasce
mentre preparavo dei muffin alla banana
e mi è sembrato molto strano il fatto
che un italiano con tutto ciò che la
cultura della cucina italiana ha fatto
nel mondo preparasse dei muffin alla
banana e così ho immaginato ma se un
italiano può esportare poi importare una
ricetta americana in italia perché un
italiano non può esportare un modello
d'impresa e in particolare di impresa
innovativa nel cuore pulsante in cui
nascono le imprese innovative la silicon
valley e quindi in questo gioco di ruoli
capovolti mi sono immaginato un modello
di impresa un modello di start up che
pesca direttamente dal nostro territorio
e che possa essere esportato e adesso ve
ne parlo in termini appunto di cibo e lo
faccio per tre motivi principali primo
perché mangiare fondamentalmente
risponde a
una di queste due cose o entrambe
mangiare una necessità un bisogno di
sostentamento per il nostro corpo ma
mangiare anche un piacere come ci
testimonia il fatto che siamo qui tutti
insieme esattamente come creare
un'impresa steve blake che uno dei più
grandi imprenditori americani uno dei
teorici delle imprese innovative di
stanford direbbe con impresa nasce per
soddisfare un bisogno una necessità
quindi immaginate un azienda che produce
carrozzine per persone tetraplegica
oppure per soddisfare un desiderio uno
sfizio no
immaginate un azienda che produce
macchine che vadano a 300 chilometri
orari
il secondo motivo per cui associo
l'impresa alla cucina e perché molto
spesso tanti imprenditori molto famosi
hanno associato già il mondo del cibo al
mondo dell'imprenditoria
ricordate la frase stay hungry stay
foolish di steve jobs non siate affamati
siate folli nella mia esperienza
americana la frase più significativa
che ho incontrato e che associa
imprenditoria e cibo e questa di guy
kawasaki che dice hunter planner stones
like it they like to bike c'è agli
imprenditori agli intraprendenti non
piace solo mangiare a loro piace
preparare e cucinare per gli altri poi è
chiaro che prenderanno una fetta di
questa torta ma lo faranno quando la
torta sarà diventata sufficientemente
grande da
dare da mangiare a tutti a tanti se non
altro il terzo motivo per cui parlo di
start up e cibo e perché quando si parla
di fare una startup quando una un'idea
innovativa subito gli viene detto ma che
ci fai che stai a fare qui in italia
devi andare in silicon valley perché lì
è il mondo delle startup e questo è vero
ma fino a un certo punto perché non
immaginare un mondo in cui tutto
italiano in cui le star top sono
possibili
che c'entra questo col cibo e la cucina
italiana ha avuto tanto da dire a ha
tuttora tanto da dire nel mondo abbiamo
esportato un modello di cucina italiana
e siamo riconosciuti per la cucina
italiana perciò così come il nostro
corpo
impara a odorare
dal cibo ed al territorio
che in cui si trova
perché non provare a
rivisitare il modello di start up che
tipicamente americano
partendo dal territorio partendo dai
sapori locali e facendo in modo che
questi semi germoglino attraverso il
talento delle persone e diventino un
modello esportabile
la ricetta che vi propongo stasera si
chiama start up alla barese
in particolare attinge alla cucina
mediterranea
proprio perché propone un modello
d'impresa che l'ing
agile essenziale frugale che esattamente
come
bisogna impostare l'impresa affinché
possa essere competitiva e innovativa
cosa c'è di più sperimentale che non
trovarsi davanti a degli strumenti per
cucinare a degli ingredienti cos'è una
ricetta tutto sommato una ricetta è la
formalizzazione di un esperimento
culinario esattamente come una start up
una start up non è una versione in
piccolo di una grande impresa come
direbbe appunto steve blank una start up
è tutta un'altra cosa
e proprio una sperimentazione un periodo
che va da 3 a 5 anni quindi un tempo di
cottura un tempo di preparazione che va
da 3 a 5 anni in cui le persone che
compongono la startup
hanno il compito di trovare un modello
che sia scalabile e ripetibile che cosa
intendo
una ricetta come ho detto è la
formalizzazione di un modello una
ricetta di una start up e propone un
modello che può essere implementato
ovunque nel mondo più o meno allo stesso
modo quindi è ripetibile può essere
ripetuto in italia come in francia come
in silicon valley ed è scalabile ovvero
se voglio passare da un piatto per
quattro persone un piatto per 4 milioni
di persone non devo preparare cambiare
le regole della preparazione devo solo
cambiare le dosi e questo è la
quintessenza della ricetta e riflette la
quintessenza di una start up
passiamo agli ingredienti
io vi parlerò soltanto degli ingredienti
poi ovviamente si tratta di una
sperimentazione perciò lascerò a voi
provare a creare la vostra impresa
creare la vostra start up il primo
ingrediente e l'idea esattamente come
quando iniziamo a immaginare una ricetta
l'idea lo rappresentata come la pasta
proprio perché quando iniziamo a
immaginare la ricetta possiamo
utilizzare tantissimi tipi di pasta ma
noi abbiamo una idea precisa in mente
sappiamo esattamente che cosa vogliamo
cucinare sappiamo esattamente quello che
vogliamo mangiare una start up nasce con
un'idea che come ho detto prima risponde
a un bisogno o ha un desiderio e
quest'idea è una e questo rappresenta il
fatto che una startup deve essere focus
su un concetto
per cui se vogliamo preparare le
orecchiette con le cime di rape c'è un
solo tipo di pasta ed è quello che
funziona
la seconda componente di una start up e
il team
per una buona start up servono da 3 a 5
cime che cosa intendo che le persone che
compongono una startup devono essere il
meglio del meglio ma soprattutto devono
essere coese e motivate uno dei maggiori
motivi di fallimento di una start up è
proprio il fatto che il team possa
collassare per i motivi più disparati
per questo in una startup noi vogliamo
esattamente delle cime
il terzo
ingrediente della nostra ricetta per una
startup innovativa sono le risorse
ne servirà giusto un pugno questo perché
come le idee migliori in silicon valley
sono partite in un garage le idee
migliori non hanno bisogno di enormi
risorse ma giusto dell'essenziale
affinché possano essere realizzate e
quindi servirà la tecnologia serviranno
le strutture serviranno le risorse umane
serviranno anche i fondi per portare
avanti un'idea però dovranno essere
centellinati utilizzati in maniera
frugale questo perché
un sovradosaggio di risorse rispetto
alla pasta no al team quindi all'idea
oppure ai componenti
non permetteranno di gestire le risorse
stesse non permetteranno di realizzare
un piatto saporito come dovrebbe essere
il quarto ingrediente sono i partner ne
serve giusto un pizzico proprio perché
devono essere veramente selezionati ma
soprattutto devono intervenire quando
ormai la fame della sete tolta perché
quando siete veramente affamati voi non
state a pensare se la bistecca e
sufficientemente salata ma è proprio
quando iniziate ad assaporare il sapore
più
delicato della carne allora li di te beh
adesso un po di sale non ci sarebbe per
niente male i partner sono quelli che vi
aiutano a realizzare le attività che vi
permettono di creare la vostra impresa
utilizzando le risorse che avete a
disposizione voi oi vostri partner
il quinto ingrediente
sono gli investimenti che ho
rappresentato con l'acqua
perché perché fondamentalmente una start
up così come una ricetta è un'equazione
poi avete la vostra pasta la vostra idea
che dovrete necessariamente
mettere in un contenitore pieno d'acqua
quindi ci vorranno delle risorse per far
maturare la vostra idea per far cuocere
la pasta
però
questa pasta può cuocere soltanto se c'è
il fuoco che identifica sostanzialmente
quante risorse bruciate per ogni unità
di tempo cioè quanto denaro impiegate
quanti soldi investiti quanti soldi
impiegate per realizzare la vostra
ricetta
ora gli investimenti così come l'acqua
in una ricetta devono essere il giusto
troppi investimenti un sistema magari
come quello americano che per certi
versi è un po dopato in termini di
investimenti diluisce molto la vostra
ricetta e alla fine il sapore ne risulta
compromesso e soprattutto la pasta
risulta scotta non so se avete mai
mangiato pasta all'estero però ve ne
potete accorgere
ora la ricetta si compone di questi
cinque elementi e ovviamente
indipendentemente dall'idea alla base di
questa ricetta componendo team idea
risorse investimenti e partner
ognuno
con un'idea innovativa può realizzare
una startup secondo alcuni criteri io
non vi parlerò adesso della preparazione
di una start up perché un percorso
indipendente che non si può insegnare vi
darò giusto alcuni spunti che ho
raccolto negli ultimi mesi e nell'ultimo
anno sia in california che diciamo
nell'attività che sto realizzando
il primo è people with che nel senso
siate spregiudicati ma fatelo con cura
un intraprendente di fatto sfida le
convenzioni c'è un passaggio molto bello
di un libro che si chiama il principe di
niccolò machiavelli che dice che non c'è
niente di più difficile da attuare che
l'innovazione perché cambia totalmente
delle convenzioni e quindi per farlo
bisogna essere sufficientemente
coraggiosi avendo cura però delle
persone
proprio per questo un modello di start
up che nasce in un territorio e che è
ispirato a una ricetta mediterranea non
può avere il profitto quindi il capitale
come unico risultato ma proprio la
redistribuzione
un altro aspetto dell'essere
spregiudicati e il fatto di essere
disruptive e disruption king è quello
che vi permette di generare idee
rivoluzionarie
però l'introduzione di idee
rivoluzionarie richiede una preparazione
dei vostri interlocutori le menti più
brillanti che hanno generato idee
straordinarie
molto spesso non sono state comprese nel
loro tempo proprio perché gli uomini del
loro tempo non erano in grado di
recepire l'innovazione e quindi dovete
fare framing cioè
comunicare nella maniera opportuna
quello che state facendo filtrare la
vostra innovazione le vostre idee
brillanti
lasciare che sedimentino nella gente
nella mente delle persone
il terzo punto è
explore the righteous ovvero sfruttate
gli strumenti che avete a disposizione
una ricetta si compone di ingredienti si
ma anche di strumenti
noi italiani abbiamo una risorsa
fondamentale che sono le circostanze
e soprattutto in questo momento storico
noi pugliesi abbiamo veramente la
capacità di giocare un ruolo nel mondo
dell'innovazione
in questo momento ci sono veramente le
circostanze il periodo economico
turbolento una voglia di attivazione una
rabbia all'impossibilità di trovare un
posto fisso che creano le condizioni
el'humus
necessari a sviluppare innovazione
quindi se c'è un momento per fare start
up è esattamente questo e se c'è un
posto dove si può fare innovazione start
up è esattamente la puglia il
mediterraneo in generale
in particolare ci tengo a dire noi
italiani siamo visti appunto come i
bamboccioni trentenni bamboccioni in
fatto di riuscire a
rimanere a casa ma di fare esperienza
all'estero ci permette di
mantenere gli assi le spese basse e di
investire nel nostro futuro una delle
regole delle start up è proprio quella
di non investire risorse non necessarie
di essere agili di essere
essenziali frugali nell'uso delle
risorse
il quinto spunto e give something that a
una start up non è profitto
un'impresa non è necessariamente
profitto noi siamo abituati a un modello
imprenditoriale che è fatto sulla base è
stato costituito sulla base di anni in
cui l'immaginario stato vilipeso da
mallett modelli imprenditoriali di
arraffoni sostanzialmente
l'idea
e il momento richiede ed implementare un
modello che sia differente che sia
passato che non guardi solo al profitto
ma che bardi a chi guardi al beneficio
sociale
dell'imprenditoria che guardi appunto al
territorio perché lì come ha detto
nascono le idee
e l'ultimo spunto è
un ex big bang non pensate che non
pensiate che una start up sia il lavoro
della vostra vita così come non è
possibile per trovare un posto fisso non
è possibile crearsi un posto fisso con
una startup una start up così come una
ricetta
nasce per essere un'esperienza
nasce per essere consumata nasce per
essere metabolizzata e già in sé gli
ingredienti hanno in qualche modo la
morte e il riciclo e così come una
ricetta nasce per creare valore essere
consumata assimilata essere apprezzata a
una start up nasce per morire e non è
l'idea di un azienda che rimarrà per
sempre
perciò
fatta una startup pensate già quella
successiva
e questo il senso del 2 next big thing
e con questo ho finito il mio breve
quadro sulle start up e perciò non mi
resta che augurarvi buon appetito